vogliono poi si è vero che a soli e
benvenuti questo video sono felice oggi
siamo sul secondo episodio ma sulla
seconda parte dell'episodio di e chris
della di lunedì oddio questa la seconda
parte di at least del ultimi episodi di
f.liszt che avevo divisi in due parti
perfetto quando ho detto quindi questo è
aprire il sema ciancio levande partiamo
col video che tanto ciò dei capelli che
non possono essere messi su youtube che
mi censurano bella ci vediamo dopo la
serie mai abbastanza
mi scusi posso tornare indietro che ho
lasciato le gambe no va bene
a preferiresti giochino che avevo già
fatto l'altra volta preferiresti morire
lentamente ma senza tanto dolore oppure
morire velocemente ma con tanto dovevo
raffa al cuore sarà lentamente 75 per
cento ha risposto lentamente grazie al
pene preferiresti che i tuoi capelli
toccassero terra e non tagliarli mai più
dure rasati fino a farti caldo non
riesco a immaginarmi calvo sinceramente
ragazzi ho paura di che cos'altro
potrebbe chiedere a dio non lo sapremo
mai perché sono caduto dal poco
fantastico gol extreme a questo e questa
è questa lo so cosa posso fare femme
deforme skyview stream
cosa ho detto sta andando avanti è morto
mio figlio troppo voglio anch'io se non
arrivo alla fine che cosa devo fare a
parte di morire di user vajda certo
guardone sono vivo anche le mie scarpe o
jumping chi cif med che di jump
voi non avete visto niente abu dhabi che
c'è un jump da dove john cena che noi
eccolo perfetto john cena o cazzo anche
io perché vanno così tanti livelli della
abitabili su su questa cosa non ho mai
capito bello se ti sta inglobando come
se non ci fosse un domani anche se non
ha senso perché il tavolo e dall'altra
parte cazzo questi si chiama colpo di
culo ragazzi e una nuova mossa di steam
o rock swing mister little j al massimo
ti puoi chiamare il mister favi j non
l'italjet è un robot di persone ma chi è
figlio mi devo attaccare alle persone
fantastico e sono capace a farlo e credo
spero mi devo attaccare è attaccata a
cazzano ci sono ci sono macchie affidata
le vostre canoe
questa è la tua testa tra restituisco se
mi fai vincere bravo ecco infatti hai
mentito soffrirai di atroci sano sei già
morto stessa di fortuna di questo guarda
vinco subito creativo advanced è mica
che culo sono riuscite a perdere senza
neanche lanciare la palla male direi che
con questo testo la mia fortuna è a
posto
cioè nel senso che non ci sono dubbi
almeno o almeno quello la palla se la
stanno stuprando è in teoria non
dovrebbe andare così
cos'è sta roba
siamo alle hawaii e c'è il bar maltempo
però se morite mi fate un piacere grazie
grazie grazie tantissimo grazie mani
anche tu grazie e più dietro prendili
quarti regalo più costretto a vedere gli
occhi tutta la pista howard addio ti
risparmio questo è lo risparmia mi
dovresti ringraziare crea di pianeta
hicks ma perche si lo è don't mean a san
fermo conferma la mia testa mi fa male
la testa ma che fido tre sono i miei
compagni meglio controllare di fuori di
cache animazione e meglio di un film di
tim burton quindi devo andare vabbè
andiamo di sotto ragazzi anche se non ho
capito
bocciamo file un ragno c'è un ragno
gigante qua dentro
non c'è nessun radio cazzo salve mi
scusi mi fai anche abbastanza schifo
quindi grazie agli tecnica come si esce
che merda giampio need to create
ucciderlo dove saltarci sopra ok
mamma mia che schifo non sei neanche più
grande che io abbia mai visto quindi non
farsi non dar viarie che carini che cosa
facciamo
sono carichi lasciamoli tranquilli sono
carini epic soccer save spiegatemi sì ma
è entrato con lui insieme a tutta la
squadra praticamente salva come la salvo
in pronuncia arrivò mai a che per star
di mad preso no attraversa di mortacci
sua madre ma o in difficile impossibile
addio a
non entra e gol forca e la possibile
nuovo luogo di cura o fuga ed i contro
nano ciak
[Musica]
mi chiamo eddy china mira che pazzesca
crede infatti lo di madonna tragedia un
action movie moving center ma bello era
un urlo di guerra oddio oddio che figo
no vabbè che volete fatto fa sta roba
che figata
vedevo bene stato figlio è stato figo te
lo concedo zio questo era veramente figo
dakar da ragazzo li facciamo un paio di
miei livelli fregi premi contro il più
vbg i primi contro più video contro pn
frigé canti come un cane è strano tua
sorella cantava abbastanza bene in
teoria ma perché livello e cimino è
proprio solo un livello nel quale mi
dici di premere contro lu
ma se tornassimo nativo all'argomento
tua sorella fa vj mangia i bambini che
capalle ha certo a pj torturato famiglia
e sarai torturato a dire cose che non
avresti mai neanche pensato di dire come
davanti un altro dove dare la risposta
sbagliata e se sbaglierai tornerai di
nuovo alla prima domanda perciò quando
troverà senti
la divina commedia come si chiama fa vj
lorenzo mi puzza il culo si chiama mi
puzza il culo giusto gli piace che mario
lo ucciderebbe lo ama da morire zio
spiegami il senso di questo dipende ti
prego è una cosa che non ho mai come si
iscrive il suo nome fa vj ho fatto mi è
piaciuto al mio livello non mi è
piaciuto mi ha fatto cagare esatto ed
era ed è mai infatti devo dare quella
sbagliata quindi devo dire sì mi è
piaciuta tantissimo quello che ho
sbagliato
ciao favi spero che ti piace altro la
vittoria è tra i vari suoni buona
fortuna buona no anzi scusa con anno non
l'hai scritto giusto né da una parte né
dall avis level of four fa vj duro duro
cosa ha capito capit questo video è
piaciuto se non siete così discreta il
cammello oggettivo bella ragazzi tutto
[Musica]
credo di avere appena giocato al più bel
livello del 2016 ragazzi non ho
assolutamente obiezione accolta ragazzo
li facciamo che concludere qui perché fa
vj duro chi l'ha duro la vince
e credo ragazzi spero che vi dove sia
piaciuto scusatemi sei più di sono
uscito ieri ma l'ho fatto uscire
soltanto oggi
però ripeto volevo giocare assolutamente
ahram bad perché col gioco mi manda in
fissa perché mi è piaciuto ma senza vita
bisogna strumento è un mi piace anche a
pagina di facebook come nei video
giocate trovate nella descrizione mista
impappinandosi su santo se non siete a
quesiti iscrivetevi ci vediamo al
prossimo video ai ragazzi
[Musica]